that's all I have left 2 these kids and a
memory
that is wildly
stained, fada they are extremely huckster
washing schock 75 and 100 in half a year
on the
site
we never
talked for so long, but during the war, not when I
was still in the last seconds, the shields wanted
say on the phone and the connection was
so bad, but I immediately
call him back on the connection, there was no longer
one
fifty dollars of that
source and no kosis bdds, this is Fiji set
like he has money and
if the opponent,
when possible, only I was pregnant,
it was happiness, they simply incredibly
weak set  or we didn’t go, we
flew, we fluttered, and when you only need him
from twins, it was double happiness
every day I talked with them, I
organize until they hear nothing, they call him, he
sits down, he talks
on the phone, there is such a calendar,
pregnant every Monday, they all
read it out how the children are formed, what is not
hears how the eyes how the ears open well at
night did not expect the children
amber
sandfall intensely or you next matvey he closed the
subscriber
somehow
they reminded  nay tattoo with noise it is necessary to choke
further mom we must live for him we can
only live if you
show us attention
this is my my strength
my strength and I have them support I
don’t have stops anymore because I will sometimes be for me
a bulletproof vest and
all
this find  heidi fighter
prank groin without
adding scania from meijin and not any time